the phrase right now for now always
jumps out at me and it jumped out
obviously it hit jim trotter and steve
weich in the same way
for instance what's the difference right
now those two words what's the
difference for instance
i could sit here and say jim trotter is
my favorite guest on the rich eisen
or i could say jim trotter is my
favorite guest on the rich eisen show
right now
right jim that's the difference
significant
[Laughter]
welcome to the program sir what a sound
bite you elicited along with steve
yesterday what you know i'll i'll give
you the floor on what you
what you thought of it jim well first
off let me say this i had never met
or spoken to david cully before uh
yesterday
and just came away completely impressed
with him his energy
his passion i even said to him if i
could suit up and play for him right now
i would
that's how impressive he is
now having said that you know look rich
what have we heard this off season
um we heard the ram situation with jared
goff when gm lesney was asked about it
and was jared goff going to be their
quarterback for the season and he said
he
is at the moment and so when you say at
the moment you open the door to the
possibility that he won't be
going forward and sure enough jerry goff
was traded
go back to the josh rosen situation a
year after he was drafted in the first
round by the arizona cardinals
gm steve kim was asked is josh rosen
your quarterback
and he said he is right now and shortly
after that josh rosen was traded
so when you hear a head coach say of a
player who is disgruntled and clearly
has ex
has privately at least expressed that he
does not want to
return to the team that he is our
quarterback
as of right now your antennas go up
but what took it one step further for me
in that interview was later in it
i tried to press him again to say you
know look
is he your guy is he going to be here
and he said
we are moving forward and we are moving
forward with
those that want to be all in
we know desean watson is not all in and
that's why
you know i don't mean to put words in in
david culley's mouth but that's what i
took from the interview
that desean watson will not be there
that they will ultimately
look to move them and the other thing
the other piece of this puzzle
is that a week and a half two weeks ago
we had jalen ramsey on the podcast yes
you did
and jalen ramsey is a close friend of
sean
they both have the same agent and david
muguletta
and we asked jalen ramsey did he believe
deshawn or or specifically the question
that i asked him was
how serious is desean watson about not
returning to the texans
and he said extremely serious
and he said he did not envision desean
watson ever putting on a houston texas
uniform again
now he prefaced that by saying that's
not from
any inside knowledge or anything like
that that was his opinion
but i have a hard time believing that
jalen ramsey would make that statement
without having some sort of conversation
with someone involved jim trotter here
on the rich eisen show we played that
sound bite as well
i mean uh your your huddle and flow
podcast has been
uh hot to the touch to say the least
with some of the
conversations and this is one of the
most unique um
quarterback can't call it a holdout it's
not there yet and
and and that appears to be because i
think was it you or steve who asked the
question
as a follow-up too of jalen ramsey that
might have been you jim that this is
going to be a test that's what
management will do
you know management management will say
you're our guy
or right now or whatever whatever you
know kali said or whatever
you know and then he came on and it was
a little bit more strong at his press
conference later on in the day
more lockstep with management speak
which is you know
uh the test is coming and that's that's
that's the thing i don't understand why
the texans
won't do this right now when you can
play things off between the dolphins and
the jets and the bears and the niners
and whoever and create this crazy market
and go pull the trigger which
you know um will replenish all the draft
choices that they need
but at some point though at some point
they're gonna force desean to
not appear somewhere and and and desean
is going to feel
like we're going to hear things that
he's not
he's not a team player which is insane
or he's not
uh he's not somebody he's somebody
looking out for money even this isn't
money
uh is a test is coming jim and i don't
understand why the texas
you know you know this too it's it's a
it's a um well-worn adage in the nfl the
deadlines for action
and right now there is no deadline for
the texans to do a deal as we get closer
to the draft that's when i believe
things will ultimately heat up
um not before you know we still got a
lot of time until then so
um look the texans i believe went into
this
uh believing and wanting to have desean
watson at their quarterback my
understanding is that
the candidates they interviewed for the
head coaching position they made it
clear that they wanted to retain tim
culley
as their offensive coordinator because
of the possibility that deshaun
might stay out until let's say week one
of the season and if he returned at that
point
they wanted him to be able to hit the
ground running in terms of having an
offense that he knows
a coordinator that he's comfortable with
and a verbiage that he's comfortable
with
and so what did they do they retained
tim kelly but if desean watson is
serious about
not playing for the texans again and i
take guys like jalen ramsey at their
word who know him
and knowing desean watson's character as
a man
i don't believe that he would do this if
you were not serious
and so from that standpoint i believe
the texans are going to have to ask
themselves the question here
is it better to have a hundred percent
of something
or a hundred percent of nothing and when
they get to that point
i would hope the answer that they would
find is it's better to have a hundred
percent of something
so again i don't expect anything to
happen
anytime soon but i think as we get
closer to the draft
that's where we're going to see some
sort of movement and look the other
thing here too rich is
the texas are not simply going to give
him away i mean we're talking about
a young franchise quarterback
on a multi-year contract now
that looks even more favorable knowing
that when these tv deals kick
in how the salary cap is going to
increase who's arguably one of the top
three quarterbacks in the nfl
guys like that you don't let out the
door for nothing and so
he could set the market for what you
know compensation should be involved
in a trade of this magnitude so um
there there are different factors here
that all have to play out for
this to work for deshawn to be able to
get out of houston
but i do believe that there are teams
out there that are willing to pay
whatever that compensation is
to get a quarterback of his caliber well
jim trotter i mean i i follow
joe banner on twitter as well i think he
might have retweeted something you
tweeted out or something that was
tweeted about
your your your podcast and what
soundbite you elicited from david culley
and he said essentially that
letting watson go or trading would be
one of the worst decisions in the
history of professional
team sports because of everything that
you just said that makes him such an
attractive
quarterback to have on your roster you
know
all all that said though i'll push back
a little bit here and say that maybe a
deadline is next week
look nick casario knows belichick
wouldn't make a move like this because
of
of how much money and how much also
capital it would take to pull it off
but i point this out to say that the
patriots are
off the table now because they have cam
and anybody else that makes a maneuver
you know right like i don't buy things
okay so that's what i'm saying like
that a deadline right now a free agency
before anybody takes their
chess piece off the board because
they've signed somebody that would be
some deadline maybe in the next week you
want to do it right now is when i would
think
no look you signed cam to a one-year
deal
that's not going to stop you from
signing a desean watson and first and
foremost too i don't think the patriots
have the capital
right um to to make this deal so i i
don't even consider them in this
to me the teams the three teams you
would have to look at most
would be um the dolphins the jets
and the panthers and selfishly speaking
as a san francisco native
i would hope the 49ers could find a way
to jump into that because the idea of
desean watson with kyle shanahan makes
my head explode
i know plus they're also on the nfc
which is where i imagine houston would
want to send him
and that's the point too here too jim is
that is that desean has a no trade
clause
so they have to kind of work together to
make this happen
and um you know but the reason why i
brought up new england was
not that it would be a viable
destination but the fact that
that there may be somebody that takes
their piece off the board
through a move in free agency so that
now would be the time to strike
now would be the time to do it and you
could play all these teams off of one
another
before free agency right rich
you know this league as well as i do
when you have an opportunity to go after
a young franchise quarterback who is
already on a multi-year deal
all of the things you just mentioned
aren't going to stop you from doing that
you move heaven and earth to get a guy
like deshawn watson and i believe that
that
ultimately the texas will play these
teams off of each other
i believe that and just to wrap it
doesn't make me right no no no i
i i i'm with you jim i'm so with you
there's no doubt uh
i i think this is inevitable um
and and and that's just one one last
thing i want to
talk to you about is what you and maybe
you and steve together
um have gleaned about what is desean
watson's
side of this plan he does have a no
trade clause
he does have a microphone anytime he
wants he could
choose anyone he wants in the world of
nfl media
or his own social media because it is
content and it is the 21st century
to make a statement to say this is what
i had a problem with this is what it's
been all about this is what i have told
the texans i don't want to do
they have not listened i want out and
then changes the dynamic of
absolutely everything what is his plan
has he given
teams to the texans best you know that
they get these are the teams he wants
like what has he done other than what we
think he has done which is demand a
trade and speak to david cully and tell
him so
let me just say this to you rich without
overstepping my bounds here
once this thing is all done
you will hear from deshaun watson
throughout
this entire process let's just say it's
it's being chronicled okay
and i'll leave it at that okay
that's a little bit critical i mean like
it's there's a crew that's
shooting this right now is that what
you're saying behind the scenes it's
being chronicled
you will hear from deshaun watson when
this is all over
when do you think we hear from him in
the in the interim
will he not say a word i don't know that
there's any reason for him to speak
he's been very smart about the way he's
handled this because
obviously rich you know this anything he
says is going to be twisted to fit the
narrative that the person
restating it wants it to fit so there's
no benefit for him
as much as i would love to have him come
out publicly right now and say something
there's no benefit for him to say
anything right now
and so he's not he's just going about
his work as jalen said he's a servant
leader
he's out doing things in the community
in houston as well as other places
he's there for his current teammates
when they need him and he'll continue to
do that he's a man of character
so there's no reason for him to get
involved in a back and forth right now
with the texans
publicly um he has spoken to david
culley
he um again i better not go there
um let's just say he has spoken to david
culley and i think we all know what his
position is
well a man of character if he's going to
be forced to as you even pointed out
i think to jalen that he's going to be
tested and they're going to try and make
him
to choose between his money or his
his uh i guess public persona and
character being impugned
and the texans won't come out and do it
themselves i mean you know
it'll it'll start being out there yeah
he didn't show up to otas even though
it's virtual
well he didn't show up here you know and
then it'll be
the microphones will be put in front of
the texans again at some point though
if if the texans are not moving and they
do try to
put him in a position to choose his
money or his or his public uh
character um he's gonna say something
right i mean he's not gonna be silent
the entire time
throughout this process i can't speak
for deshaun
i'm not i'm not a part of his team of
course so i don't know
i don't know at a point he would want to
speak out
if any before this is resolved all i
will say to you
rich as you know there are people who
are going to attempt to tear deshaun
watson down regardless of what he does
regardless of what he says and so from
that standpoint
for him the best thing for him is to do
what he feels
and his team feels is best for him and
to live his life for himself
and not for anyone else so again as a
media member
i would love to hear from him right now
but as a person
i understand completely what he's doing
and to hear from him on the huddle and
flow podcast no don't
jim right uh that would be tremendous he
has
he has an open invitation to come on our
show just like he does yours you know so
and everyone else is like literally he
could pick and choose what he wants to
do
whatever he wants absolutely absolutely
absolutely
or or rich yes well let me stop there
yes you are right
you are right you keep on going down you
keep on taking that step
jim just you keep and then you you pull
up you pulled me back in
you know you you had you no i i know but
rick i'm not trying to get myself in the
middle of something here right you know
you get older you get wiser you learn
when to shut up and it's time for me to
shut up on that
i just say to you again deshawn has an
open invitation
to our show just as he has on any other
show
jim who's next on huddle and flow
because again you guys have been killing
it
it's been great um actually we're going
to bring back
our first repeat guess we're going to
bring back soledad o'brien next week to
talk about this project that she's doing
um regarding race in america so um
she was one of our early guests and
she's just so talented so smart
and and has empowered so many people
particularly young women
women of color um that we want to bring
her back and have her talk about her
latest project
well she's on mine next week too jim
that makes us
uh is that right yes she is she is on my
new podcast just getting started she's
got a great story about obviously
getting started in her
in her business and then restarted uh
after uh she parted ways with cnn and
she's running her own business and
you're talking about all the great work
that she's doing so yeah
we got uh we got yeah talk to her talk
to her about her family and and
high achievers and and telling the
family that you know what
um i think i'm going to take a year off
of school from
from harvard to uh to be basically be
you know an intern or an entry-level job
talk to her about that uh it's a it's
it is already done it's in the can and
and she is phenomenal and i can't wait
to hear her on your podcast and
i thank you for the call here today jim
appreciate it
my pleasure rich anytime my friend right
back at you that's jim trotter my
colleague from the nfl media group check
out his podcast with steve weich
huddle and flow hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here